what happens when you paste the name of
a classic movie on a bad movie and call
the thing a sequel let's say the results
are less than stellar in the case of s
darko stick around to see the full list
of lame cinematic follow-ups
horror films and psychological thrillers
are gold mines for unnecessary add-ons
and plenty of franchises like hellraiser
and child's play for instance which have
spawned numerous sequels that don't add
much to the original story in many cases
these sequels end up going direct to
video or straight to streaming nowadays
which usually indicates that their
quality is substantially lower than the
original one of the most egregious
examples of this is the direct to video
sequel to mary herron's american psycho
the classic slasher film starring
christian bell as serial killer patrick
bateman released two years after the
original american psycho 2 all-american
girl stars mila kunis as a college
student who becomes a murderer during
her time studying criminology christian
bale isn't in the film but patrick
bateman does appear albeit played by
someone else with his face never shown
the connection to the first film is
small but that's because there was
originally no connection at all american
psycho 2 began as an original screenplay
called the girl who wouldn't die but was
undeservingly given the american psycho
title late in production in a
transparent bid to capitalize on the
original film's success it was a cheap
cash grab that definitely resulted in
more than a few disgruntled blockbuster
customers i have to return some
videotapes the blair witch project
changed the horror game when it arrived
in the summer of 1999. one of the
earliest examples of the modern found
footage genre the story of three film
students lost in the woods was an
unprecedented success that spawned a
sequel only a year later however it
wasn't originally supposed to be
released at least not that quickly after
the blair witch project broke the record
for the best budget to box office ratio
in american history its distributor
artisan entertainment wasted no time in
green lighting a second installment
while production company hacks and films
didn't want to rush it artisan pushed on
regardless choosing to move forward
without the involvement of either of the
original blair witch directors troop
crime documentarian joe burlinger took
the helm but even he was dissatisfied
with the final product after studio
executives made sweeping changes to his
initial vision the final product was
book of shadows blair witch 2 which came
and went with little fanfare or praise
the blair witch franchise was rebooted
with another installment in 2016 but the
magic of the first film still has yet to
be replicated and it's hard to believe
that it ever will be
the bourne identity kicked off the born
franchise with a bang telling the
exciting yet thoughtful story of an
amnesiac cia operative on a mission to
discover his past while not every film
in the series was universally acclaimed
the first three were positively received
bringing in a combined 950 million
dollars at the box office while the
bourne identity was an adaptation of the
first installment of robert ludlum's
best-selling trilogy of novels that
didn't mean that production on follow-up
film the bourne supremacy was a foregone
conclusion matt damon the face of four
out of five of the films in the
franchise has commented that the born
identity was never made with a trilogy
or even a sequel in mind according to
damon expectations were low due to a
number of production problems along with
the film's release date being the same
as the live-action scooby-doo even
though the mystery gang brought in a bit
more cash the bourne identity defied
expectations and revolutionized the
action genre for years to follow harold
remus caddyshack the 1980 comedy about
the workers and members of an elite golf
club features an all-star cast that
includes bill murray and chevy chase
after the pitcher surpassed expectations
and catapulted rodney dangerfield to big
screen stardom warner brothers requested
a sequel and things got complicated from
there production on caddyshack 2 was a
mess right from the start an initially
apathetic reimus only agreed to the
sequel at dangerfield's request but when
numerous story ideas and rewrites left
dangerfield unsatisfied he and remus
dropped out of the project a few months
later chevy chase was the only original
cast member who would end up appearing
in the sequel albeit in a smaller role
the actors who replaced the original
cast as well as their new characters
were the final nails in the coffin for
this troubled sequel with terrible
reviews and dismal box office returns
caddyshack 2 is a follow-up that
reaffirms that some ideas should just be
one and done
brian de palma's 1976 adaptation of
stephen king's carry is nothing less
than a horror classic the tale of a high
school outcast who wreaks telekinetic
havoc on her bullies has not only been
remade for film and television multiple
times over the years but also inspired a
sequel that was released a whole 23
years after the original set within the
same universe as the original film the
rage carrie 2 centers around a young
woman named rachel who has power similar
to carrie and uses them to exact revenge
on classmates who drove her only friend
to suicide much like american psycho 2
the rage carrie 2 started as an original
story but the powers that be thought
that making rachel and carrie related
would boost ticket sales despite the
return of amy irving as sue snell it
didn't work the rage carry 2 was panned
by critics and failed to make a profit
once a studio decides that it wants a
sequel there isn't much that can stop it
from happening but it definitely doesn't
help if the people responsible for the
original film want nothing to do with it
one filmmaker who was particularly
uninterested in returning under studio
control was richard kelly the filmmaker
behind the 2001 science fiction coming
of age film donnie darko although donnie
darko didn't do well financially on
initial release it's since gained a cult
following thanks to its enigmatic plot
that follows a troubled high schooler
who's seeing visions of a strange man in
a rabbit suit i met a new friend
real or imaginary
imaginary in 2009 the sequel s darko was
released centering around donnie's
youngest sister and featuring a
similarly strange plot according to
kelly however not only did he have no
involvement in esdarco but he's never
even seen the film and has no plans to
watch it anytime soon that's probably
for the best considering that critics
and moviegoers didn't seem to like it
either even though he hasn't released a
movie since the box in 2009 kelly has
promised his own d'arco follow-up in the
future
william friedkin's 1973 blockbuster the
exorcist is widely regarded as one of
the best horror films ever made
frightening in a way that few movies at
the time were able to match the battle
between two priests and the demon
possessing 12 year old reagan spawned a
franchise that includes several sequels
a television series and a reboot trilogy
slated for 2023 william peter blatty the
author of the novel the film is based on
produced the first film and wrote the
script winning the academy award for
best adapted screenplay since the
exorcist was one of the biggest films of
the 1970s warner brothers was hungry for
a sequel but neither blatty nor friedkin
were interested in signing on regardless
production on exorcist 2 the heretic
eventually went ahead with a new writer
new producers a new director and the
return of linda blair's reagan as a
young teenager dealing with the trauma
of the previous film's events whereas
the first film elicited scares the
sequel drew anger and laughter from both
critics and moviegoers failing to meet
financial expectations in the process
vlady eventually returned to write and
direct the exorcist 3 which was released
17 years after the original and
completely ignored the events of the
heretic the three cool got much better
reviews and has many more fans but it's
still not as universally beloved as the
original
sequels typically arrive no more than a
few years after the films they're
following up the odds of success tend to
fall the longer it takes but a long wait
can still end up with a big hit that
wasn't the case unfortunately for
gremlins 2 the new badge the sequel to
1984's gremlins showed up in theater six
years after the original and despite
earning positive reviews it had a dismal
box office run director joe dante didn't
want to make a gremlin sequel when
warner brothers originally asked but he
eventually agreed on the condition that
he could have full creative control
dante's vision resulted in a film that
saw gremlins invade a new york city
skyscraper featuring several instances
of wildly anarchic meta-humor the new
batch didn't catch on during its initial
release but it's acquired a cult
following over the years there's plenty
of fans hoping that they'll live to see
a kremlin's three
it's one thing not to be interested in a
sequel it's another to be forced into
one thanks to a contract that's exactly
what happened to jan dibont director of
the runaway bus action film speed de
bont felt that the story of speed had
reached its natural conclusion but the
surprise success of the first film meant
he was contractually obligated to make
one anyway thus speed 2 cruise control
was born replacing the bus with a boat
and keanu reeves with jason patrick
speed 2 failed to recapture the
excitement of the original despite
featuring the always entertaining willem
dafoe as the main villain even though it
featured one of the biggest most
expensive movie stunts of the 90s cruise
control is only talked about nowadays
when listing the worst sequels in
cinematic history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]